foreign
and welcome to today's webinar rethink
high content screening part 1 why all
technology doesn't cut it in the new
world I'm Christina Ortiz and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by our Sally
biosciences to learn more visit
ourselfbiosciences.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions
um as we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit them
um if you have any technical issues
um in the same box if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Dr Maggie ventanglee policelli
director of marketing at rsla
biosciences Maggie you may now speak
um begin your presentation
awesome thanks Christina and thanks
everyone for attending our webinar today
we appreciate you taking the time so
I'm going to give you a brief overview
or you know of how we at Araceli have
decided to rethink high content
screening
um so we're going to talk a little bit
about the high content environment and
then move into what we identified as
key opportunities to address bottlenecks
in the workflow
um we had and we'll talk about this in a
few minutes we had a really unique
opportunity at aracely to start from
scratch on our platform we do as
possible technologically to build a
better system and we didn't have a
reason not to so today we'll cover a bit
of our path and how we at aracelia are
rethinking the high content screening
workflow technology and greater space
um so it's worth noting today in the
time that we will complete this webinar
so approximately an hour
um we on an Araceli platform we would be
able to acquire more than 9 000 Wells of
data
analyze that data and produce graphical
visual results for any user on all of
that data
um so that is representative of more
than six 1536 well plates in four colors
um so just keep that in the back of your
mind as we talk about the advances in
high content
um that we're working on at Araceli and
providing at Araceli
and as Christina said please share any
questions you have in the chat
so laboratory Innovation over the last
20 years has really sped things up
um and multiple different environments
obviously there's been a huge revolution
in genomics and high throughput
screening really is high throughput
right so you can with high throughput
you get an ability to assess the effects
of compounds but generally that's tied
to one or very small number of data
points for every specific assay or
sample
on the other side of that we have
genomics which generally is looking at
you know a whole genomes worth of genes
but usually with one donor at a time
obviously there's techniques to pool and
then we have where we like to live at
Araceli which is in automated Imaging
and with automated Imaging or high
content screening
traditionally you're looking at
thousands of variables measured per cell
but it's very very low throughput so
what we have built in Araceli is the
ability to make high content screening
High throughput screening
um many of the assays that users are
used to using in a
drug Discovery lab or drug development
lab are those High throughput assays
where you're getting answers and results
in seconds to minutes whereas oftentimes
high content workflow is giving you
results and taking more than an hour to
scan your plate and then an additional
huge chunk of time to analyze that data
so it just doesn't really fit currently
in with the expectations of many users
in that environment
so
these techniques for high content have
been generally
stagnant for quite some time and this is
also a space that's Rife with
bottlenecks and problems
so
we accomplished at Araceli what no one
else has done and built a high
throughput imager but that we realize
that that is not the full solution it's
not just sufficient to take more data
faster right so the question we often
get from customers is okay great you can
take more images but what do I do with
them that still doesn't solve the next
bottleneck and the next bottleneck so
you can see on this graphic here this is
a really simple representation of our a
generic high content Imaging workflow
where you have sample prep you have
Imaging on the high content instrument
you have a desire to do some quality
control of those images then you run
your future extraction analysis you have
to deal with data management you have to
move the data and then oftentimes you're
doing some type of data mining or
statistical modeling Downstream
so the sample prep issue of generating
enough samples for high content has been
addressed by the industry there's
numerous liquid handling modules out
there there's an ability to generate now
a lot of samples so the next bottleneck
has been the ability to image all of
those samples
with that there comes problems if we
address that bottleneck the next
bottleneck is going to be on the quality
control how do I know I'm taking good
data how do I analyze all that data
because it's not sufficient to take
you know a full plates worth of images
in minutes and then still have to spend
hours and just push that backlog
Downstream
so we chose not to just look at the one
bottleneck of Imaging of the actual time
to acquire data we've addressed that
issue as we'll show you today and we
will also show you some Snippets of work
that we're doing at Araceli to adjust
the other parts in the workflow
as part of our like one of the real
benefits at Araceli is we are have been
able to build this platform from the
ground up and we have looked at every
single part of this workflow
with scientists that are using this in
their day-to-day work
and like I said while acquiring data
faster was a major concern there are
lots of other bottlenecks we have had to
address and so it's worth noting that
our current platform addresses the
Imaging bottleneck right so our our
Hardware offering which we'll talk about
um but then these other
bottlenecks Downstream we're addressing
those with a new exciting launch next
year in early 2023
. so what this looks like for users and
kind of the traditional high content
workflow
is
you've always had to make compromises so
we have you know our little triangle of
compromise here on the slide
where you know
you have speed image quality or
resolution and Sample coverage so we
define sample coverage as the amount of
a well like in a multi-well plate that
you can acquire
in a high content experiment so
traditionally you could usually pick two
of these but you never got all three
with traditional high content Imaging
you could acquire data really fast and
get full well images but you were using
a low magnification objective that you
didn't convey additional resolution or
any kind of improved resolution so that
was always sufficient for doing nuclear
counts General morphology assessments on
bigger structures
but it was not something that you could
get subcellular resolution at high speed
and full well
the flip side of that is if you wanted
to go fast an image at high resolution
you only had one or two Fields per well
and they were tiny so you really didn't
get a robust sample number or
representation of the sample within your
assay
finally if you wanted to go get your
full well you were looking for rare
events and you wanted that image
resolution you were talking hours upon
hours to scan a play and we had in my
I'm in this industry I've seen a lot of
people doing that and you know scan
times of six plus hours per plate are
not unusual for those types of
approaches
so we really chose to go after this
problem of having to compromise and pick
between these different points of the
triangle with our platform offering at
Araceli
we also kept hearing that it was hard to
use there was a lot of training burden
for customers and
we'll share some more on this later but
number a number of our customers have
told us that it can take up to a year to
bring a scientist up to speed on all
their platforms because typically they
don't just they're not just doing high
content they're not just using one type
of high content system there's different
systems within a lab so it's a constant
cycle of training and retraining people
because as soon as they get trained up
they leave so because we didn't have to
fit a pre-existing software architecture
or framework or something that had been
around for a long time
we really took the opportunity here to
start fresh and design the best tool and
offering for the job of the scientist
that is using our platform
finally the biggest thing that we had
after was how long it took to get
accurate data
um so this wasn't like I said before it
wasn't just
a matter or a matter of acquiring data
faster it was acquiring quality data
that you knew was good quality faster
and getting to your time to results
faster so you could do the next study
the next experiment the next thing that
you have to accomplish and really reduce
that cycle time
so low quality data analysis makes you
have to revisit data setting your
pipeline back even more and segmentation
errors propagate throughout your entire
data analysis Pipeline and even if
people don't realize that doing high
content you're constantly making
decisions using traditional segmentation
methods on what is good enough
right so traditional workflows have you
set your image segmentation parameters
on your
positive controls and your negative
controls and
typically you have to make a call as to
like what is good enough you're going to
miss a cell is that okay you're going to
miss this punct is that okay and and
people all throughout that process you
are making decisions that impact the
downstream quality of your data
it might even just be subconscious bias
but at the end of the day you might be
missing a whole population of cells that
because you didn't acquire it or because
you didn't include it in your analysis
could skew your data in a different
direction so we really wanted to focus
on delivering high quality results in a
simple to use interface that were
impactful for our customers
and we didn't just want to think and get
stuck in a group think mindset at
Araceli
um
we wanted to make sure that what we were
bringing and what we thought were
problems in the field actually were so
we asked people and we you know I'm not
going to read all these to you guys
um but we constantly kept running into
people wanting to do high resolution
imaging much faster wanting to take
advantage of high resolution to do
techniques like cell painting right
phenotypic profiling techniques wanting
to go faster because of the demands of
cell painting which we'll talk about in
a little bit
um and needing to train their users and
something that wasn't going to take them
six months to a year it was something
that could be walk up they had
confidence that anyone in their lab
could walk up and use that system and
acquire good quality data
you don't want to have someone cut loose
on a system have them start acquiring
data and then find out two weeks down
the road a month down the road or even
later that the data that they have been
acquiring is garbage
right the exposure wasn't high enough
the settings weren't quite right
it's there was some problem with the
staining patterns so the all we took
this to mean that we needed to start
fresh
we wanted to take on these big problems
that we knew hadn't been addressed in
the last 20 years of high content
systems being on the market there have
been incremental improvements over the
years with the addition of CMOS cameras
of LED light sources to to improve you
know five percent throughput here 10
throughput here but in reality we are
still all living in a land that
there hasn't been a major technological
shift outside of putting a microscope in
a box and enclosing it and automating it
in over 20 years
we knew based on all of our research and
our experience doing high content that
there were huge bottlenecks and can
speed constraints and we also knew we
could actually be the ones to do
something about it
at Araceli we weren't tied to a platform
and a box that was already manufactured
we weren't tied to a software
architecture that meant that we had to
stick within a framework and not go
outside that box we also weren't tied to
just the mindset of we've always done it
this way so we're going to keep doing it
that way
we kept hearing over and over again from
everybody to make you know we need to
make this easier I need quality control
tools that I just know my data is good
quality and I just need it to be fast
and easy
you think about just consumer products
in general anybody can pick up an iPhone
and figure out how to take a picture
that was our unifying goal with the
Araceli platform
so what we are talking about today is
covering the
vision for high content screening that
is the core of Araceli biosciences and
what we've brought to the market we are
focused on delivering phenotypic
profiling at high throughput speeds so
we're not talking an hour maybe 30
minutes to scan a plate we are talking
every plate under 10 minutes full well
four colors that is our goal that is
what we bring we are approaching those
and bringing the high content screening
workflow into that high throughput state
we really believe in giving people
confidence in their data we want that
data to be interpretable and we also
know that the traditional image
segmentation workflows that we've all
relied on for years
can be better with
the huge improvements in computing power
and the massive field shifting changes
with artificial intelligence machine
learning deep neural or sorry deep
learning networks we knew we could bring
something to the market that was way
faster and higher Fidelity than anything
out there in the market right now that
would really be transformational for our
customers
so what does that mean right so what
what is the value and why bother it's
not just about speed it's about getting
higher better quality data
today with the Araceli platform high
content is high throughput because we
can do whole well high resolution
multi-channel imaging in under 10
minutes
and we've built the analysis to be
faster too
um so what this means is you know when
we're talking about why why does full
well matter or why do I need to go
faster it's because all of the major
techniques right now and the the kind of
shiniest newest techniques in high
content analysis are all looking at
feature extraction in bulk right so it's
not just the days of is my nucleus green
or not is my cell green or not which
those assays work beautifully on
Endeavor it's we need more data we are
living in the time of big data and what
we know is more data isn't always better
but more quality data is better and that
means faster or acceleration of
pipelines that means your ability and
your scientist's ability to make better
decisions at the bench as to what the
next experiment should be and not have
to wait two weeks for analysis
um and we're also seeing a huge increase
not only in cell paint type assays but
in the need to do and look at rare event
biology so you might have one cell in
your well that is your positive that you
need to characterize maybe it's a quad
labeler tri-labeled cell and literally
out of a million cells there's only one
that means you need to capture the whole
well and you shouldn't have to wait six
hours for your plate to scan to do that
at the resolution you require because
that if you if you don't you might miss
that candidate what if that what if you
missed that option
if you're not capturing the data you
can't know what the data includes so the
the value in the full well is really
giving you confidence that you've looked
at everything and reduced error bars
right so you're not subject to if you're
only looking at samples in the center of
your well any type of plate washer or
staining aberration that's altering
morphology of the cells you're you're
looking at everything holistically
so we think of the Araceli platform as
the ideal cell paint solution due to the
throughput
of the platform but we can we can talk
more about that as we go on today
so when we think about rare events some
of the work our customers have been
doing is simply looking for a rare
mitotic event it could also be those
quad labeled cells so oftentimes when we
tell people that we are doing full well
Imaging they think of us as just another
okay well I I can count nuclei that's
fine but this this slide can really show
you the power and the resolution we
deliver at Araceli so not only are we
doing full well Imaging and capturing
all your biology but we are able to
tease out mitotic spindles and we can
analyze those with our Downstream
analysis tools it's not just you know
let me tell you what size my cell is we
can look for these mitotic cells outside
of this whole population
um the way we did that is we built the
optimal Optical path for high content we
chose to go for high resolution with a
large field coverage that gives you
speed and resolution
so one of the common questions we get is
you know what magnification is it
um and honestly our system delivers
0.27 Micron pixel resolution and we have
the range of magnifications that
everybody wants right so in Traditional
High content you'd always talk about I
need a 4X I need a 10x I need a 20x lens
if you're getting the full well at high
resolution you don't need it we give you
that every single time every single
plate that you put into an Endeavor or
Araceli platform you end up with this
type of resolution
so another example of this sorry me got
a little stuck here there we go
um another example of this is a 96 wall
full well image
um and this is showing you that we
acquire this whole well at high
resolution and we can clearly Define
subcellular features like DNA damage
Foci in this example here across that
whole well
um and you're not making a sacrifice to
get this so this whole plate in these
three colors was acquired in about seven
minutes
um
same that's it right so it's it's not
you know if if you only want to acquire
a subset of the well we could do that in
about 30 to 40 seconds for this example
but you know if if it only takes seven
minutes to acquire your full well why
why wouldn't you right so
um we really really believe in giving
you all the data and all the information
from the cells that you've worked so
hard and spent all your money on to prep
so we're talking about a platform that
delivers outstanding image quality
across the whole well and we've we've
benchmarked our throughput we've talked
about this you know because because
people always say you know it's high
resolution but you obviously you only do
that if you you know look at a lower
resolution image or you know we can't
there's no way you can hit those speeds
how do you do it because we're making we
realize that we make very very bold
claims at Araceli about our capability
and where we are compared to where high
content has been for a long time
so we have benchmarked our throughput
and we've done this time and time again
we've done this with customers and what
I can tell you is we have the ability to
scan a 96 well plate in four channels
with laser autofocus there's not like
all the caveats here that oftentimes
these speed specifications have
and assuming a 10 millisecond exposure
per Channel which is pretty standard on
our system you can acquire 96 well
plates in under seven minutes and four
colors full well that translates to 183
96 well planes on one high content
system a day with automation but more
importantly and where we really see
people get excited is that with 1536
well plates we can do those in about
nine minutes and that translates to 140
1536 well plates on one system in one
day with automation with assuming a 24
hour run time
um so this is
Way Beyond anything that's on the market
right now and this is why we are High
throughput
um so we're able to give you all of that
contextual data from a cell-based
Imaging assay in this time that it takes
you to do a traditional you know
fluorescence intensity measure or Plate
Reader assay
um in those kind of more traditional
High throughput screening environments
so we really really believe in tearing
down all of the kind of gatekeeping of
high content that's existed out there
um in the market and one of the things
that begs the question is well are is
the data you're acquiring high quality
right so and this is not just something
that we hear from Araceli this is
something we've heard from our customers
from
forever you know my previous rules I was
always out supporting customers and
training them and it was always a
question like how do I know my data's
good enough how do I actually know so we
took that feedback and we put effort
behind making sure that you're not going
to analyze bad data we are going to make
sure that analysis is worth your time
before you do it even though it only
takes a few minutes it's still the right
thing to do
so we have the ability within our
platform to
flag data that is either out of focus
you can see in this example here there's
some in the upper left hand image
there's like a stack of dust that's
slightly above the focal plane that's
throwing off the image we can flag that
with a quality metric score so anything
red here closer to 100 is a better
quality anything reduced from that is
lower quality so we can see on this full
representation of our 96 well plate here
that we have some wells that are
questionable right so there's probably
dust on the bottom there's maybe there's
debris in in the wells themselves like
the example in the bottom left so we
have the ability to flag that and that's
seconds for us to do we're not talking
this is another huge massive step of
your workflow this is something that is
almost real time for the images so you
can know right away if you should
analyze this data and we're not just
flagging things that have debris or have
like Focus quality issues or dust or
scratches on the bottom of the plate
because if that's important we can also
flag whether there are tip strikes we
can understand and determine whether
there has been a staining problem in a
certain well and I don't have the data
in the presentation today to show that
but that it's we're not just talking
like one a one-trick pony that can flag
one thing and move on so we've really
really focused on making sure that you
should be able to filter your data and
also you know if your if your data needs
to work like do you want to have that
taking up storage space do you want to
have that just sitting on your drive
um should we go back and rescan it is
there something we can do to salvage
that sample so we this is super critical
when we talk about our analysis workflow
as well so our focus is is just making
sure that
our customers have peace of mind so that
is true for data quality that is true
for our analysis which we will cover in
a moment but that's also just proof true
for our acquisition software
we have made the decision and because
we've been able to start over from
scratch on the platform and build it
from the ground up that
we wanted to make a simple and easy to
use acquisition software everybody says
it's easy to use
um their platform is easy to use it's
simple and we just have people try it
right so our our challenge to everybody
on is that we know we're making bold
claims sign up for a virtual demo come
see the system we're able to show this
to anybody and get you trained in 15
minutes or less
um so we really designed this from the
ground up to be able to control the
complexity of the software every single
decision we made and continue to make
about software design is made in the
context of the end user and what the job
is that someone needs to do and move on
to the next thing we do not want this
system to become something that someone
has to spend their whole day running one
single plate and getting through the
software
it's it's just another piece of the
workflow for our customers
so that begs the question
um you know if we can scan in under 10
minutes and generate all this data what
happens to it how how how do you get
actionable interpretable data from that
so we have launching in q1 of 2023 our
new image analysis solution
so we've chosen to move away from the
traditional image segmentation toolbox
of pre-processing and allowing users to
just kind of set thresholds based on
size and intensity because we all know
that that can be problematic for certain
masks for a number of assays and you're
always making biased decisions on what
is good enough and what isn't so we have
built a platform that is working off of
all the latest and greatest technology
in the artificial intelligence space so
we utilize deep learning we utilize
machine learning and we offer neural
networks for detection so our deep
learning does the work for you and we
have trained the algorithms to
distinguish biological features in any
environment
we are the experts on high content on
our sorry on
um
image analysis and we've built that into
our product so that our products become
your image analysis expert
so our algorithms have been trained to
distinguish those features and
what it means when they've seen it all
is we have trained on enough sets of
biological features that new things
often will just work right so you're not
stuck in this one of the fears I've seen
a lot of customers have around
artificial intelligence in general is
this perception that you have to train
these networks for hours and days and
weeks and it's tons of clicking and it's
it's almost diminishing returns and how
do you know when it's good enough and
how do you know if it's good enough or
how do you know if you should train more
and one of the things that we've built
into this product is the ability just to
to go right so we've taken that on and
how we've built our product and how
we've
deploy this to our customers
to make sure that you're not sitting
there doing training it's just going to
work right and and if if you need
additional help we can do that we offer
data annotations or data science
Services
um but it is so simple that people can
just do it and the most important thing
here is that
it was absolutely critical that we built
this software to keep up with Endeavor
the hardware offering we did not we were
not going to accept something where we
can scan a plate in seven minutes but it
takes three days to analyze the data so
we're talking some something that we are
compressing that entire workflow down
into minutes compared to hours days or
months from previous iterations of high
content
um and here's some proof of that
so this assay isn't this is an example
assay where we were just looking at
punct analysis this is a 1536 well two
color assay with a nuclear scene and a
puncta scene in a separate Channel and
this assay was looking at punctum
morphology punct accounts and intensity
and we were able to conduct that full
plate single well analysis in three and
a half minutes and that includes the
segmentation the feature extraction and
the plotting
so it's worth noting on this assay we we
Benchmark this against cell profiler on
the same system
um and cell portfolio took an hour to
run this plate
um but it is worth noting that the
pipeline development by our experts took
a lot of additional time and those are
people that have used cell profiler
extensively and this is not a knock on
Cell profiler this is just saying that
Voyager can keep up with the data our
our platform can keep up with the data
that is generated by Endeavor and we're
talking results in minutes so for this
assay it took us seven and a half
minutes or so to scan this plate and it
took another three and a half minutes to
run the analysis
11 minutes to you know endless numbers
of data points is is a game changer in
the high content screening space
um so this will be launched at slas in
2023 so if you'll be there please come
by our booth
um if not we will we can you know hang
out virtually with us too I'm sure so
um we're really looking forward to
seeing and sharing this with the greater
the greater high content screening
um environment and Community
um in the first quarter of next year
so
in summary what what does all of these
improvements that I've shared with you
today mean for in the actual context of
a Lab
right so you know if if you're a lab
where you've you just need to get
through and crank through
an immense amount of plates this is the
platform for you so we acquired data in
we can run screens in hours or days not
months and that context of that screen
could be you know 100 plates we can run
that in a day on an Endeavor and we can
analyze it
um that for other types of setups that
could mean instead of having one user
take up your system for a day running
all their plates you might be able to
get five users in and run all their
plates
um and most importantly
this is an accelerated decision cycle
we're not just speeding up the Imaging
we're speeding up the Imaging the
analysis and we're allowing people to
make a decision
so from to move from the biology in a
plate to a decision on the biology in 10
minutes or less
and this decision cycle is now it's
compounded and it's cumulative so it's
cut down for every single step moving
forward for your organization and you're
saving hours every single day so in
general your return on investment for
the platform is paid with the
acceleration of results the acceleration
of findings and the ability to make
better decisions faster
so overall we like we definitely have
re-thought high content and we've
reimagined high content from the ground
up so we have built an ultra fast imager
that is capable of
providing phenotypic profiling at high
throughput speeds
we have a system that
brings that power into your lab in a way
that doesn't require your team to get
trained
for weeks to months to taking up to a
year to get trained it's minutes
and this is something that can deliver
confidence in your data with
interpretable results through our
quality control from everything from our
quality control metrics to our analysis
Solutions
um
it's important noting that we are
constantly innovating we are constantly
adding to this capability and we are
just super super excited to keep sharing
this with the larger field so like I
said we will be launching our image
analysis solution at slas in 2023 in
beautiful San Diego
um but we have some ability to show some
stuff behind the curtain right now so
please reach out to us if you have
questions
um and overall you know this what our
platform is what the Araceli platform is
is our high content screening platform
is made up of endeavor which is our
Hardware offering our new analysis
software coming just very shortly and we
also offer the ability to scale the
Endeavor with our automation Solutions
um Endeavor can also be integrated with
other
automation Solutions
um but the best thing to say is we have
made some really really bold claims on
this webinar
um we've you know said that we can we
can do in 10 minutes what it takes other
systems to do hours
um and we recognize that that is a huge
shift fundamental shift in the space of
high content Imaging so I would advocate
for all of you to say that the best
thing to do is come see it whether that
is at slas
um and the U.S or Europe next year
um there's some other conferences we'll
be attending or our live virtual demos
we are constantly offering those and we
encourage you all to come see it for
yourself
um and then follow us on LinkedIn
Twitter Instagram or sorry Instagram uh
YouTube
I swear to God I know my social media
channels
um and then I you know
it's worth noting that my my webinar
went a little bit faster so I think you
know in the time that we've given this
webinar and about 35 to 40 minutes we've
got Endeavors that could scan probably
five of those 15 36 well plates so a
little bit closer to like the 7 000
Wells but I still think that's a huge
improvement over
um
barely making it through the first
quarter of a height uh 1536 well plate
on any other system on the market so
um with that said I just want to give a
quick thank you to the Araceli team for
all of the support in getting this
webinar off the ground getting the
product off the ground
um you know Christina our moderator has
been phenomenal and help not just
moderating
um Matt fueve on the Araceli team has
been essential for generating a lot of
the beautiful images that you see in
this presentation and then of course
Mike shostad has been a critical member
of the team moving helping us get this
off the ground and the larger Araceli
team we're always super excited to go
and
um
share with you and
you know get the best policy and the
best feedback from from our industry
so at this point Christina I think we're
ready for any questions that the group
might have
yes um thank you Maggie for your
informative presentation uh we're gonna
start the Q a section of the webinar so
if you have any questions now
um please click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll start we'll answer as
many questions as possible with the time
being
um so let's get started with our first
question
um
so how does your artificial intelligence
and machine learning based analysis
differ from traditional methods
great question
um so many ways but overall
um you know it really depends on the
method so it's worth noting and I think
I forgot I didn't
um
share this
on the discussion is
um or on the webinar is number one
generally it's very fast
um so
oftentimes we can acquire a plate
actually faster than we can acquire the
data significantly
um and we have our number one goal for
analysis we'll always run as fast as
acquisition but oftentimes we're much
faster than the acquisition
um so number one is speed but our
really what versus traditional methods
one of the most critical things is that
what we found is having just one tool in
your toolbox is not anything like that
is not where anybody wants to be right
where you have
um
one thing that you can do and do it well
and our analysis platform is built in a
way that we have the best tools for the
job so traditional image segmentation is
one tool and it does not work for every
assay our offering is built in a way
that we have deep learning we have
machine learning we have some other
proprietary
um Ultra fast methods for doing image
segmentation and future extraction and
Analysis that
we our goal is to bring and Design This
platform in a way that someone can just
use the best tool for their assay you
know it might some assays it might not
you might not need all the intricacies
of like a highly trained deep neural
network and you might not want that
because it might take a little bit
longer to run you might want something
that you can run in 30 seconds and we
have a tool for that within the software
so basically overall the overarching
difference between Ai and ml is
and traditional methods and to simplify
this very quickly in the image analysis
space is that we with traditional
methods you often have to set things
using either a threshold for size or
intensity and if there's a difference in
intensity in a different well because
sustaining wasn't good enough or
something happened or there's just a
little bit of bleaching you might miss a
complete Well's worth of data you might
just throw that you never acquire you
never analyze that data
because you're only looking at you know
a couple parameters for what determines
a cell with
these ai-based approaches you're looking
at what a cell is it's it's you know the
difference between saying an animal with
two pointy ears and two eyes okay is
that a cat is it a dog versus saying I'm
looking for a cat give me a cat and show
me the pictures that are a cat
that's the biggest difference
awesome
um so another question we have is What
technological advances have you made
that make your system so fast
it's a great question everything
um so when we designed Endeavor we we
really started from the ground up
um you know
the traditional high content methods
were awesome and they were game changers
in their time
um but we decided not just to take
another microscope and build a box
around it we really looked at every
single part of what constitutes an
optical path what constitutes the
computer that runs the system what
constitutes the analysis software and we
looked around not just within Life
Sciences but other Industries where
speed and throughput are essential for
work
we redesigned the Optics and we're using
the fastest available Hardware to ensure
that we can acquire data Ultra fast
speeds we've also taken every
possibility to streamline and
parallelize within the system and within
the software
awesome
um and then you mentioned Automation in
the webinar but what what automation
options do you offer currently
yeah so we
um
on the previous slide we have a listing
for our Endeavor GT option that is a
hotel and arm
that is controlled by or sold with bios
arrows green button go Control software
so that's really designed for users that
just want to buy the full package and
get started this also fits into existing
workflows we have we like to use the
Sila 2 interface for device connection
but basically any capability that you
have for automation we can get Endeavor
working within that with you know kind
of the typical
driver feeder type of workflow so
anything that's working on your current
Pi content system
just a matter of plugging this in
instead
um
and then another question is how big is
the instrument how much space would it
take on a lab inch
okay great question so
um Endeavor was built to be
um it's roughly a 26 inch Cube so it's
26 inches wide by tall by deep but it
can fit on a 24 inch depth wide bench or
depth death bench sorry
um so it can go on to 24 inches but it
it you know it's it's certainly not as
compact as a Plate Reader but it does
also does not take a full Lab bench or
you know a full room or something along
those lines
okay
[Music]
and I think that's all the questions we
have so far
um Christina I see uh there's one other
question I think
um it raises a good question I think
it's worth addressing
um on running 384 and 15 36 well plates
for 3D models
um
we are
we have run some of those tests so
there's a question in the chat let me
reiterate that
um that said have you timed running 384
in 1536 well plates with 3D models that
requires these stack images
um yes and no so I will give you the
caveat that this the speed always
depends on how big the things are that
you're Imaging
um what I can say is
it's not surprising if you have to
acquire more images and see that the
system goes a bit slower but it is still
way faster than anything else out there
so we've done you know some
five slice stacks on 3D models
um with about that would cover about
like 10 to 15 microns we've looked at on
you know 384 and 15 36 oil plates and
that can take anywhere from you know
20 minutes to about 40 minutes it
depends on a lot of the configurations
but it's still way faster than anything
on the market a lot of that depends on
exposure time but it is still designed
to be ultra fast we really like to stick
down on that that 2D environment just
because it allows us to look at this and
really
embrace all the benefits of the Endeavor
speed but it certainly does translate
over into the offering better throughput
on those 3D models as well it really
depends on the the biology that you're
looking at
you
um awesome thank you Maggie
um
I think that's all the questions that we
have uh today
um so thank you Maggie again for your
time and before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
um questions that did not get answered
today you can submit them during the
on-demand period and we will be they
will be addressed by Maggie
um uh she will get in touch with you and
then these kids this webcast will be
able to be viewed on demand lab routes
will send you alerts via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share it with as many of your
colleagues and contacts as possible
um and until next time thank you very
much and goodbye
thanks everyone bye